et à les bloquer essayez-vous joujou le
tout cas on va fêter la sortie de jack
wilshere
si vous êtes raciste en vous êtes
l'assistant personnel
il est midi c'est un beau mec non tu
travaillé ensemble mais c'est mon ami
est allé aux toilettes c'est la gauche
oh oui vous avez quel âge c'est
simplement parce que out c'est 25 de
travail fin vous êtes marié me marier
non non pas mariés il est
et on peine 20 rebondir
non elle disponible et pourquoi quand tu
es toi comme tu es marié tu n'as rien
non on pense aux avec moi et j'ai eu un
vrai alors est ce que c'est possible ou
pas et c'est délicat mais parce qu'en
fait lui une cravate ont fait bien plein
d'artistes les états unis en fait moi je
sais et j'ai été mis en contact des plus
en fait moi j'aimerais bien que tom
cruise tom cruise je pense qu'il doit
faire un show c'est touche pas à mon
poste
une seconde peau qui me pousserait
désolé voilà c'est tout c'est à fond
c'est quoi n'aurait attikpa ballon
laissé ma fiancée
il est très gentil oui gentil comment
très longtemps gentil comment alors ce
soit par exemple il te plait il te plaît
qui te plaît ah ben il est magnifique
j'ai rien du tout vous démaquiller donc
j'ai pas de avant parce que d'habitude
un peu mais la météo a également créé
les gars ggp des sushis parce que vous
apparaissez blanc mathieu non non non
mais mon film mais moi je te suis donc à
ta des trucs ce soit ce soir je saïs
travail obama travaille tout est ok par
les feux d'une france c'est pareil c'est
pour ça qu'on veut tom cruise 1 yart
voilà donc comment est ce que moi je moi
j'aimerais la voir
c'est ce mardi il veut de la monnaie
unique résume avec un son différent
c'est de l'argent
une prestation fifteen ces années 50 et
70 6 0 pour qu'il vienne dix minutes
70000 euros ça coûte plus cher que
l'émission non666 mais c'est pas mon
problème en fait celle d'autres îles de
temps non mais on peut pas donc pas mais
je vais t'expliquer quelque chose 18
juin 18 mois je ne paye jamais aucun
invité ce soit on cruz ou même où barack
obama alors pour par la voix alors que
tu me fais venir tu me dis que c'est
mais non mais non mais franchement
j'adore l'émission massive de tequila
non mais non mais non moi je ne perds
jamais fous-moi de tom cruise j'aime
bien ton cruise mais si tu me tues tu en
penses
alors je paye pas les invités donc moi
c'est clair non mais tu me fais perds
mon temps
ok c'est au garden qu il nomme estonie
chaos qu en fait ses débuts voilà donc
c'est toi qui veut de l'argent c'est un
entraîneur à la faisons télé j'ai dit
voilà
mais quels canaux économique de swiss et
matin va alors on s'en cogne papa hockey
comme raphaêl encore nous fait perdre
mon temps je suis au bout du quai victor
sera fatigué il était saoul tarif là ok
ok nique nique which was il ne bouge pas
on ne touche pas au cas où à ok mais tu
me dis ça sans annoncer les choses il
sait franchir lors du match [ __ ] on
est dans la merde
mathieu je suis pas appel ce qu'on fait
là on touche après touche à beijing et
qu'il est bon ça va on appelle un
médecin un non mais tu es fou non mais
si on appelle un médecin pour tout le
monde va tout le monde te rends compte
ça va ça va tout le monde va le savoir
comment on fait posez-vous tu veux dire
alors là c'est la première partie du
piège
et là le piège va se refermer sur
matthieu delormeau à mathieu laças un
film américain vous avez peur de toi là
bas qu'est ce qu'un combat voire de toi
maintenant mais ce que je vous dis c'est
horrible ce que vous allez voir dans un
aspect c'est vraiment le pire du pire
sonné ça n'est que de la fiction je
préfère vous le dire
c'est inquiétant que vous excuser autant
je vois déjà des cibles demain cyril
hanouna accuse matthieu delormeau
d'homicide involontaire
je vous le dis battus et vous aurez tout
le débrief également jean-luc vous avez
le beau que le gros des brises de ça et
vous verrez un truc qu'on a filmé dans
la loge puisque j'ai fait le débrief je
les dis le lendemain à mathieu de la
route c'était une caméra cachée
il s'agit pas que c'était aussi dans la
loge et c'était film et mathieu donc on
verra tout ça voilà rejoindra quand
c'est terminé ou mais bien et c'est dans
la merde et personne a dégoupillé
derrière c'était vous voir pour vous
faire passer une bonne nuit
d'accord ça s'est bien passé non vous
verrez la suite de cette caméra cachée
dans un instant je vous jure que c'est
un film américain a tué ça va ça c'est
que mathieu ne m'a pas parlé pendant 24
heures et même pendant trois jours et
était très bizarre avec moi et je ne
parle toujours pas votre garde du corps
exactement femmes c'est ça un dégoût
autres assistants venant non mon ami
will see merci ça va ouais on va
raconter parce qu'il a passé un coup de
fil même très bizarre une personne nous
raconterez tout dans les moindres
détails pour le moment
chez la suite de l'histoire c'est partie
remise et vous tu m'aimes bien
à riom c'est quoi ça non mais sérieux on
s'est embrouillé avec le mec là on
s'embrouille avec le maigre et poussé
parce qu'il a on a permis de souffler
quand il ya quelqu'un d'autre dans la
maison n'ont personne barça nous aimons
est à but non mais est ce qu'on peut
faire
j'appelle les flics dit c'est toi qui
l'a poussé vous êtes embrouiller ce qui
l'a poussée sera plus facile que dire
syrie de la pousser dans la merde c'est
rien c'est soit on associe reid
pour moi c'est hyper chaud frérot
éthiques mais non mais moi trempe
outlook scandale que ça va faire mais
non médias rien l'ange de juin
parce que toi le mec des sushis ta vie
moi personne m'a vu moi je peux partir
je dis que j'étais jamais là dans ce
rendez vous mais je les appelle leur dit
que c'est aux normes et leur dit pas on
leur dit rien on appelle le samu le samu
on a marqué et après on verra
la police et on dira qu ils vont venir
pour amener les années si le mec là des
séquelles si j'avais dans ma maison ça
appelle le samu plutôt que deux et c'est
là c'est ce qu'il faut c'est sauver non
mais moi je me casse
[ __ ] searidge qu'on va me laisser avec
un coeur comme elle est tout ce qu'il a
fait pour toi non moi j'ai rien faire
faire et en plus moi franchement je n'ai
rien fait je vais dire exactement s'est
passé diego parce que comme ça tu le
sais non mais sans déconner on était là
il sait vénère mathieu et il a poussé et
où on est tombé non mais c'est vrai que
non je te donne envie de toi qui es tu
es activités gendarmerie non mais sans
déconner moi je couvre mathieu sans
déconner c'est vrai moi je reprends pour
que je suis là c'est mathieu qui s'est
un peu venir il a voulu le mec qui sait
venir
non mais je dis la vérité main non non
mais j'ai maintenant mais je dis la
vérité il a poussé sans faire exprès
mathieu la poussée est le mec qui est
tombée sur la sur la table je te jure
que c'est ce qui s'est passé non parce
que moi personne n'a vu mais moindre
idée
mais la vérité pour moi c'est cette
vérité je peux pas de couvrir et à
supporter coup il nous faut une fois
pour toutes les nations et là ils pas du
tout je peux pas couvrir mon chéri je
peux tout faire mais là c'est toi qui
l'a poussé mais c'est certainement dire
mais non je mens pas dit la vérité non
franchement je mens pas je mens pas
c'est ce que j'ai vu les images étaient
là j'ai vu qu'elle voit jeter la gtoi
qu'est ce t'as vu moi j'ai vu club
bon moi j'ai franchement die sans
rigoler après la police n'y est pas il
appelle la police des routes
c'est lui qui l'a poussé ils peuvent non
mais on est obligé comme ça toi et moi
je vous mets moi faut pas qu'on voit
c'est pas comme moi au moins toi rester
avec lui deux secondes bon ben je ne
sais quoi pas tenues clé et je reste pas
tout seul non mais moi pour moi pour moi
mathieu moi je moi je lis dans ces
histoires là je ne rigole pas les mecs
il faut toujours dire la vérité
non mais ces engins non c'est toi qui
l'a privé où c'est toi qui l'a poussé
dan harel était comme un rêve mais ce
n'est pas qui l'a poussé à réussir un
canard mais je t'ai dis je les ai vus
arrête mathieu arrête de mentir non mais
t'es un malade mental tout écouter ce
qu'on a à faire on va faire un truc plus
un truc plus simple ou prend le corps on
le met dans la voiture on va t'en [ __ ]
on le pose en ce cas bref au moins on le
dépose moi comme ça de la fane personnes
nous avais moi je le fais je prends sur
moi je le fais et je pensais le must il
a raison je le veux mais tu m'aides à le
mettre dans la lumière - protège ma
queue et c'est moi et voilà toute façon
c'est un truc c'est motivant protège
mathieu et on fait semblant de rien
personne nous avions entre ici et ils
gagnent encore en train de te protéger
la taxe n'a rien à faire ça juste à nous
aider encore il a raison si on le met
dans le van
et on le met on le jette sur un devant
et tu pousses un mec c'est vrai qu'il
est en plus on perd du temps dans son
chariot mathieu là on perd du temps et
c'est pas bon on s'en fout moi je
faisais moins d'un mois je protège
mathieu jeudi que se dit que c'était pas
lui font là jamais vu et comme ça
personne nous a vus c'est maintenant ou
non on perd du temps là tuteur du temps
madiot fais ça tu crois qu'il ya des
empreintes des trucs indigo bell les
empreintes soient pas pris de tapas
président du champagne chez les verts
hier mathieu 4 celle vers la mecque des
soucis les tapas but en plus d'en bombe
alors quoi quoi c'est pas possible
mathieu je te protège mais je arrête
c'est vrai je te protège moi j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] se loger mais non mais
mais mathieu moi je m'en fous moi je te
protège pas le mec on le met dans le van
ba je cherchais un endroit tu vas
chercher un drap et moi je m'occupe de
la voiture tu vas chercher un grand
lahou venir un homme attend parce que là
mathieu n'est pas bien non c'est pas
bien mais c'est moi qui prends tout je
prends tout quoi j'étais moi qui vais
l'emmener à l'hôpital tu fais rien tu
rentres chez toi la vanille voiture est
bien à 0 vient avec nous j'en porte de
là va tuer le port d'armes on le porte
mais dehors attention boupère faut
peut-être aller chercher un drap la
raison - dos comme ça on le met dans un
drap ou bien on le met dans le tapis on
le roule dans le tapis on peut peut-être
mais ils vont savoir que les toits elle
s'amuse et autant je sais pas quoi
mais la france aborde cette fois il faut
être honnête je n'ai rien à branler
ouais faut savoir que cette eau moi je
dis donc c'est toi la police c'est tout
ça à mieux regarder baby pas venu
immeuble après les pompiers appellent
les pompiers un majeur mais si ici mais
c'est parce qu'on me poser de telles
questions madame abonnés il aima bien
oui c'est qui va mieux oui dit lui qu'il
vaut mieux [ __ ] on m'a laissé tomber
le steam c'est bon on accroche ça
commence à aller mieux oui c'est lui qui
t'a fait ça je viens au niveau c'est lui
tout à fait ça
erwan ados mais bientôt ce jeu prend une
douche j'ai eu un chèque à halle et
c'est mieux comme ça toi que tu arrives
et aucun lien légal - matt cutts que
thomas retourne tout cas y mettre un peu
débile suspect le oui ok ok ciao salut
alors c'est mathieu il a été formidable
matthieu protard son égard comme un film
dont j'ai envie c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai c'est un match où il est encore
émue regarder franchement mathieu
bauchet rien n'est pas viable
il est même tellement il était tellement
déçu sur la motion
mais quand on le voit comme ça mais ça a
duré très longtemps et on a vraiment cru
qu'il était mort mais il est là il est
dans le public idées d'ailleurs dominic
gould le comédien
comédien et et j'aime bien on a on n'a
pas encore la fin de magnéto
certainement dominique voulez vous ça va
merci dominique mercy mercy alors là il
était sympa merci et alors je vais vous
dire mathieu
en fait je lui ai dit que le lendemain
mais en fait que le lendemain un mathieu
que c'était une caméra cachée et 1
c'était la douche du compost avec new
providence soir dominique qui se
baladent son plateau dirait qu'ils le
gardent pas il résilie les beaux gosses
ça va et je lui ai dit que le lendemain
que c'est une caméra cachée et pendant
tout ce temps en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé vous avez même appelez vos
amis et tout ça on va la regarder pour
vous reprendre
vous reprenez vos esprits regardez la
fin c'était dans la loge quand je dit à
mathieu que c'est une caméra cachée
regardez
moi ce que je veux c'est sortir de là
parce que tu es monde est capturé dans
la mer bouchait taffin cauris j'essaie
de trouver des solutions avec une chose
est claire c'est parfait comme une
ordure mais en fait c'est une clé passe
votre d'émotion du continue aujourd'hui
au contraire je suis la porte et c'est
un fou ce 9 ans je te dis que je vous ai
dit de te sortir de là franchement c'est
comme ça ce que je suis autorisé hier
soir tout à fait le cas des factures
tout d'abord à 75 kg grande émotion j'ai
eu honte dit vous pourrez deux ont
reculé toit est en cours de
développement commenté hier je comprends
que tu soirée hier mais j'espère désolé
et pas mal et puis un matin je serais
fou mais j'ai vu un peu de montres mais
ça c'est qu'ils y croient vraiment un
combat où tout radar mais commet
toujours à tous pareils on a dîné du
paradou d'un groupe commandé le jeu
commence à temps pourquoi quand tu
casses la gueule à l'est quand un truc
de caméras cachées le mec qui tombe
illégal médecin il en double sens que
celui ci d'américains le kiné montrant
un drame dû comparer sur ses progrès et
mendient nues j'ai cru qu'il des morts
et ce que j'ai mis la main dessus comme
un peu grasse mais je connais pas le
bout et je me suis dit homicide
involontaire on a reçu une barre qui a
aucun témoin moi je fais toi et les
empreintes partout où tu as une barque
comporte mais tellement convaincu les
jeux passé la nuit en garde à vue ma vie
a basculé
mais doté de mobiliser tout évolue tout
c était en marche et un livre de famille
et les ventes depuis le cul le bocage
normand et mathieu gines et qui a été
exceptionnel je vais donc ce que ta
fille à nouveau via que c'était moi
c'est ouf
ce n'est jamais la chine sont évidemment
il ya eu encore où ils étaient sept
histoires
quelle heure j'ai rendu ce prisonnier
éventuel ménasché toulouse que même les
photos et les dix mots que j'aime bien
et tu le sais vous me connaissez notre
chef
ah la la
bon doublés et maintenant je crois que
tu m'as tu crois que tu m'aimes encore
plus qu'avant
ouais ouais mais ce qu'ils veulent ça
c'est le lendemain ouais c'est dur oui
mais non mais ça ils te regardent sont
pas contre mais pendant 10 minutes j'ai
cru que j'avais un homicide involontaire
sur les bras non j'avais prendre 50
prison c'est à vous voir contre la
mienne je peux rien faire il ya pas de
caméra y'a rien je me voyais partir au
poste voilà ta vie bascule je suis
rentré j'ai exposé en sanglots dans la
voiture je me suis fait flasher
d'ailleurs si tu vas le payer mais fait
flasher cimino et après j'ai appelé jury
vérité j'ai appelé bas mon grand frère
quand j'appelais marc olivier fogiel
ouais j'étais en pleurs indie calme-toi
calme toi viens la maison qu'est ce qui
se passe je dit juste c'est un monstre
s'amoncellent et lui m'a dit mais je
raconte l'histoire et me dit mais si les
gens savaient c'est un jubilé qui
vivaient les numéros à la télé si les
gens savaient il m'a dit je ne faut pas
que tu ailles l'antenne lendemain c'est
fini c'est fini c'est elle dénonce pas
le lendemain dit luc tu arrêtes tout est
dit que c'est fini et dans la nuit il
m'a dit je te présente u et dupond
moretti catherine avocat pénaliste
oui parce que si dans la nuit fait une
hémorragie interne ou quand il faut que
tu ailles maintenant voir il était deux
heures du matin faute et avoir un
pénaliste oktay la police jugeant peu
plus et tout ça je suis rentré j'ai faut
pas faire ça j'ai pris des débats là d
un truc un relaxant
c'est ça j'ai pas dîné tous ont serré la
main et m'a dit je veux arrêter
l'émission julie pour concevoir l'humour
et les textos dans la nuit pour dire tu
as été super bravo aux frères bryan
je me suis dit plus jamais je peux faire
l'émission avec vous même si une guerre
va bien même si le gars va bien j'ai vu
votre vrai visage
j'ai vu que si ça se passe mal vous êtes
là pires ordures du monde
c'est une caméra cachée connard
encore savoir est tu sais comme je
t'aime maintenant ouais ça va mieux oui
ça va mieux mais se recaler j'ai très
mal vécu
on peut parler de seconde ce que tu as
dit sur les autres car ça va à l'émotion
et beaucoup d'émotion émotions dit des
conneries ben voila j'ai pas eu beaucoup
d'émotions pendant ce prime ça a dit
beaucoup de conneries je pense que c'est
le moment des quatre tirs ah ben je
pense que là il ya une bonne ambiance
pour rigoler oui